c'est à bord de ce train entièrement
blindé que le dirigeant nord-coréen Kim
Jong-Un a traversé la frontière russe ce
mardi il rencontrera le président russe
Vladimir Poutine dans les jours qui
viennent notamment pour discuter du
sujet sensible les 1000 km qui séparent
la capitale Pyongyang et Vladivostok
dans l'Extrême-Orient russe sont estimés
à 20h de trajet à bord de ce qu'on voit
ultra sécurisé contre moins d'une heure
en avion pourquoi le Tout-Puissant chef
nord-coréen privilégie-t-il le rail lors
de ses voyages diplomatiques si le train
blindé reste le moyen de transport
privilégié de Kim Jong-un ce n'est pas
par conscience écologique c'est en effet
une habitude tenace de la dynastie Kim
avant lui son père Kim Jong-il a
exclusivement voyagé par le rail durant
ces 17 années de règne très peu
d'informations sont disponibles
concernant ce train vers bouteille bardé
de jaune les renseignements sud-coréens
et américains font état d'une vingtaine
de wagons intégralement blindés des
vitres jusqu'au parois en passant par le
plancher dont le poids restreint le
convoi à une vitesse moyenne de 60 km/h
lorsqu'il se déplace le train est
précédé par un premier convoi de
reconnaissance qui ne soient pas piéger
un second convoi positionné à la suite
du train transporte des membres du
personnel de sécurité prêt à intervenir
à tout moment en amont du passage de
cette impressionnante colonne une
centaine d'agents sont envoyés dans les
gares pour repérer le moindre signe
suspect malgré son apparence austère ce
train blindé et doté de technologie de
pointe des clichés datant de 2011 et
2015 montre une grande salle de réunion
bardée d’écran plats et de tablettes
dernier cri permettant aux dirigeants
suprême de communiquer en direct par
satellite avec ses équipes quant au
confort les rares personnes à avoir été
conviées dans le train témoigne d'un
intérieur des plus luxueux dans son
livre intitulé Orient-Express le
diplomate russe Constantin poulicovski
relate son voyage avec Kim Jong-il le
père du dirigeant actuel servi au Grand
Cru français le chef suprême se
délectait de Omar frais ou de porc
grillés à l'aide de baguettes en argent
il était possible de commander n'importe
quel plat issu de la cuisine russe
chinoise coréenne japonaise et française
avant l'accession au pouvoir de Kim
Jong-un jamais un dirigeant nord-coréen
de s'était rendu publiquement à
l'étranger par voie aérienne à
l'exception de son grand-père qui met le
song lors de sa visite en URSS en 1986
si c'est légèrement détaché de cette
tradition l'actuel dirigeant à utiliser
le train blindé à 5 reprises sur ces 9
voyages diplomatiques depuis 2018 soit
dans la majorité des cas un choix
sécuritaire qui semble surtout illustrer
la paranoïa et le grand d'isolement du
leader nord-coréen